you know I once got a call from Marvel
they said stop calling exciting : it's a
free video guys we're gonna watch the
day from the screen ride around eight
actors before and after they got the
call from Marvel I have no idea what was
up a Robert Downey jr. 's life
beforehand well I'm just asking
questions that's alright when you get
the call from Marvel Studios you better
answer not only is it the opportunity of
a lifetime not only will you get the
chance to play iconic heroes beloved the
world over
you also get some prime training to put
your body into perfect - superheroing
shape yeah you've gathered together some
of the most astounding actor
transformations from the Marvel it's not
like an answer anymore didn't you guys
hear not only did they reach the true is
that in many cases the receipt system
writers ain't careers - Robert Downey
jr. might very well have one of the
greatest comeback stories in the history
of Hollywood on the best probably the
greatest with the less than successful
stint on SNL
thankfully things picked up for dinner
when appeared in a series of t movie
hits such as weird science and the
pickup artist following these more
comedic rules he ended up taking the
plunge into more dramatic fare his role
in the film Chaplin even earned him an
Academy Award nomination but during the
mid-90s things started to fall apart his
struggles with drug addiction came to
the forefront and his career suffered
major setbacks he was in real footage of
never having a successful start on the
hit TV
so Ally McBeal Downey jr. couldn't seem
to get his act together thankfully at
the turn of the century he started to
get his act together again
working double-time to ensure a full
recovery from his chaotic and harmful
lifestyle at first it was a struggle
very few people would hire Downey jr.
because of the insurance liabilities but
when Jon Favreau pushed and Marvel
Studios to cast him in the role of Tony
Stark the studio took a chance and the
world has never been the same play no
further emphasizing his new healthier
lifestyle
he went from a scrawny member of John
Hughes's brat pack to the kind of guy
who loves to show off big glorious
muscular form while hammering metal our
hero feel like he had the most
reasonable buff transformation while
Chris Pratt's personal life thankfully
never mirrored the trials and
tribulations of Robert Downey jr. Pratt
still experienced some significant
changes once he was cast as Peter quill
aka star-lord in James Gunn's guardians
of the galaxy Stern is one of those guys
who lost weight and still remain funny
but many fans call Potts time as Andy
Dwyer on the whole area series Parks and
Recreation
Andy was goofy a bit clueless and
maintained a lovable teddy bear shape
and demeanor
it wasn't Pratt's natural size and
weight but he maintained it for the
duration of the series in order to
transform himself and that's right he
went like vomit and tirelessly for our
gateway to shape until his hair shaved
shave his body to the muscular star-lord
Pratt's time on Parks and Rec resulted
in audiences associating him with the
goofball type character if you expected
that he was capable of delivering the
more serious performance but even though
the character of Peter quill their
comedic guardians of the guns and prop
22 erotic beats to play to now he's one
of Hollywood's top leading men and it's
all thanks to those incredible dance
moves
Nevins career didn't start out that
dissimilarly from Downey jr. Sam Pratt's
he made his drug addiction through in
the teen comedy
Not Another Teen Movie before making his
first foray into the world of Marvel
really though Fantastic Four and
fantastic for rise of the Silver Surfer
might not have been great but Evans made
for pets your opinion a superhero fell
through he tried his hand at more
dramatic fare starring in films like
Danny Boyle's science-fiction flick
sunshine Evans gave a fantastic comedic
turn in Edgar Wright Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world - but his second attempt at
joining the Marvel ranks ended up being
far more successful it would change the
world and it's not difficult to
understand why Evans imbues the wall
with genuine humanity and sincerity it
doesn't hurt that he fills out that suit
nicely not that he was ever in dire need
of losing 60 pounds like his fellow
Chris Chris Pratt
but when Steve emerges from that pod
totally transformed it's tough not to
mutter an audible Keanu Reeves inspire
and we all I know is he was in Star Trek
that's all I'm a first in the MCU
equation karissa I actually have no idea
about unlike the other Chris is on our
list Hemsworth was relatively unknown
when he first appeared in 2011 Thor his
biggest role up to that point I've been
in JJ Abrams first a Star Trek film
where he played Captain Kirk's father
George Kirk Hemsworth had already been
in decent shape but he still needed to
prepare himself to take on the role he
trained with former Navy SEAL Duffy gave
her the same trainer Chris Pratt would
end up using to get in shape board
guardians of the galaxy they spent the
majority of their training focusing on
Hemsworth's arms and shoulders probably
to ensure that he was worthy of wielding
Mjolnir
Hemsworth ended up dating 20 pounds for
the part and has maintained the look
through the majority of his career Wow
would see section of Thor that is
alright enough he Larson was an Oscar
winner Danvers aka Captain Marvel brie
Larson had established herself as one of
Hollywood's most impressive young
talents she appeared in films like Edgar
Wright Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
destined a shot about that her biggest
breakthrough came in 2015's room the
performance earned her her first Oscar
for Best Actress it wasn't much of a
surprise when Marvel Studios cast Larson
in the coveted role of Carol Danvers her
talent is undeniable it also wasn't much
of a surprise that Larson engaged in an
intense workout regimen to play heroic
shapes yeah she ended up posting many
photos and videos of her tree Foreman's
plan together involved weighted push-ups
we're super heavy cheating on her I had
no idea that all this there were these
standard hip thrusts walking lunges and
pull-ups but honestly that little car
thing has us super impressed as you can
no doubt tell from the film all that
hard work paid off though we're more
than a little disappointed that there
wasn't a scene involving Captain Marvel
pushing a car up a hill horse herd for
bikini body shot what insane
transformations we've seen come out of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe already on
the list in the movies I've even a male
non Gianni's when he posted a photo of
this new physique on his Instagram in
late December some thought it was
photoshopped turns out it was the real
deal and Nanjiani was preparing for his
role he said quote I never thought I'd
be one of those people who would post a
thirsty shirtless Nanjiani stated in the
photos caption but I've worked way too
hard for too long so here we are it's a
stark contrast from the kemal Nanjiani
people have come to know and love from
his work in films like the big sick and
TV shows like Silicon Valley so how
exactly did he pull yours off in that
last season's really - five bears
studios goodbye
so just a dear viewer you too could look
just like mr. Nanjiani it's as easy as
getting Marvel to hire you
one of their upcoming MCU films you'll
be the healthiest version of yourself
that you've always wanted to be and
since we've broached the subject of
skinny comedians turn must be real
Arsenio may want to look like a bit
about Paul Rudd's transformation the
only one that's career kicked off in his
mid nineties with rules in clueless and
Halloween the curse of michael myers.slc
punk
which included the likes of Will Ferrell
Seth Rogen Steve Carell and Jonah Hill
hey Steve Carell had a funny
transformation to turn as the rest ahead
status is one of the funniest human
beings on the planet is likable everyman
quality made him the perfect candidate
for Scott Lang and marvels ant-man I
think our first move
what does everyman quality translate to
a muscular superhero form audiences were
pleasantly surprised - by 2050 as
ant-man to discover the 45 year old
actor had put in time at the gym in an
interview with Men's Journal rod
explained I was one of those people who
always wanted the results but never
wanted to put in the work for ant-man
and the wasp Rudd went even further
he kicked off every day with an hour of
cardio then breakfast and weights he
would do a second round of cardio three
times a week for half an hour so weight
coming up with excuses and get to work
get off your computer go outside
exercise but be sure to bet in the guy
last but not least in the slightest the
king of Wakanda himself mr. Chadwick
Boseman
before we got the call to join the
Marvel Cinematic Universe bozeman had
established and this is when the time
came to play to Chawla in the characters
first MCU appearance Captain America
Civil War perfect he was perfect at
start it also didn't hurt that he
already had a background in martial arts
- Justin I didn't know that worked an
additional four hours a day with his
personal trainer Otteson Henderson they
took particular inspiration from
Christopher priests black panther run
Henderson took great care and to
ensuring that Boseman
the characters comic-book disease and
that he didn't get too bulky it was
important for T'Challa to appear agile
and quick on his feet
we rarely stopped moving during our
sessions henderson explained to Men's
Journal
we trained like we were going into the
fight it's funny because he was probably
about those transformations he was
probably the one wave shirtless moments
it is Owen Solo fell sure you see yet I
didn't feel like there was any like you
come Lamberty shots of his body nothing
even though he was the one who was the
most shirtless and like a solo
installment of the MCU like there was no
nothing that was like oh I get it yeah I
feel like the body transformation wasn't
as punctuated in that movie and also for
good reason because there was so much
else to get excited about happening but
yeah as far as like significant bodily
overhauls ago I guess it's easy to
forget the Chadwick probably had to
throw it out a lot of times I thought
this list might have been more focused
on their careers and how their lives
changed in between not being in a Marvel
film and being in a Marvel film Robert
Downey jr. is probably the only one were
that really applied heavily other people
were just like they got more famous yeah
yeah and they got more fitted yeah
that's how most of the trajectory goes
for the actors listed here because yeah
Downey jr. does have the most ultimate
at least in our time I think movie
comeback
he went from actor who was on the rise
oscar-nominated to not being able to get
hired because of insurance policies and
suddenly became the biggest movie star
in the world and the most popular MCU
character spider-man I would say but you
know like there's an association there
with an Iron Man and MCU kicking off you
guys know I don't really need to dive
into it if I got on a Marvel movie I
would definitely work my ass off to get
a Marvel body I feel like though that
I'd be the guy who are like there's
nothing in the script or it requires you
to have your shirt off and I would push
to make sure I have a shirt listicles I
want a Marine to train me I want to be
in the gym six hours a day I don't care
if my shirt never comes off because
speaking of the Marvel bods I think for
the most part they deserve to show it
off because we always make fun of the
marvel body shots of this
your hero body shots but they really
worked their ass off to not just like
fill the suit and have the bill okay
they worked their ass off special for
the guys to have like a six-pack and all
that they're gonna want to have at least
one moment to shine you I put that work
in you put the time the sweat the energy
and also it's character-building so I
think you'd want to present it on screen
to some degree because I'm wondering
welcome ale na Gianni's and the Eternals
seems like he's just a supporting
character in it I'm sure it's one of the
main of the in Samba however I don't get
the impression from everything we've
been hearing that he is the focus so I
keep wondering or is there gonna be a
scene where you see his body or is it
just gonna be that photo that he put up
online
there's gonna be a big internal group
shot where they all turn around and the
dude shirtless and the chicks have like
you know little sports bra things on
it's getting really intense for a second
as they all like do a splash page I
think that's weakness because there's
some of them where I don't really notice
what they're doing other times in order
to justify it they make a joke out of it
like with Chris Hemsworth and Thor in
the first movie Paul Rudd's always felt
a little out of place in ant-man they
did it anyway whereas like they're
having an exchange Evangeline Lilly look
at him going oh he's actually kind of
hot with his shirt off it's a way they
edit that scene together but there was
really no reason to have a scene in
there were like yeah I get it he's
injured but it just seems like such a we
got to show his body off moment yeah
although I will say Paul Rudd doesn't
look as odd with the marvel body as I
initially expected he might well he
thought his buff though yeah he's very
good he's very fit
but believably so and that was nice you
know route out for his health as a human
being
well it's like Chris Evans in Captain
America that's a justified marvel body
shot you don't really see Chris Evans
shirtless in any of these movies like
think about it was really since that
it's really that scene the closest
that's come is the helicopter moment
whereas biceps are enormous yeah but
that's like drawing attention to his
body to enhance the scene because that's
the entire point yeah and it's funny I'd
never thought about that but we really
haven't had much shirtless Ken we've had
America's ass since then yeah
the one that surprised me the most was
brie Larson and how they never showed
you any of that working I did it for
this role I had no idea she got that
strong to fill the shoes of Captain
Marvel which makes me respect her
significantly more in the athletic
department of what she did for the prep
work there I do think though that it
would have backfired if there was some
unnecessary scene I'm sure she would
have said something about it Nick Fury
walks in Carole takes yeah I guess you
must have got him like very cut and I've
never seen like a bikini shot of her
maybe she does have something up there
but I've never seen it so yeah I was
like surprised because there's no
footage and endgame or Captain Marvel
other than the fact that she fills the
suit really well and she does look
physically strong like I'm can imagine
how cut she actually is try to talk
about a woman's body in a respectable
way that probably is very attractive and
sexually appealing without sounding like
a perv right now I'm just saying every
guy gets that like their marble body
shot yeah would you have just come to
laugh at but it does weirdly become a
different situation when it's a girl oh
you know yeah and the history factors in
somewhat differently because comic books
have always been rife with gorgeous
idyllic physiques yeah and whatnot and
so it is kind of fascinating to watch
the politics play out here because you
do have such googly shots of the dudes
and the one thing that I think is also
interesting is that we are not at a
place at least in our culture in America
and a lot of Western entertainment where
we portray female superheroes as being
really muscular and buff and stuff like
that and I'm actually kind of looking
forward to the day when that starts to
happen and maybe she hope can come along
with that because I think it would be
appropriate to start seeing some ladies
with you know the the big-ass muscles to
you know maybe not make that the 100%
precedent but I think that's a way that
you could go oh wow so-and-so got jacked
for this role without having to be like
do a shirtless shot you know like I
think it would be interesting ways to do
that for their email
as members it's like you sexually
glamorized the men's bodies but it comes
across like tough and macho when that
association doesn't often come into play
with the women because they're usually
required to get more lean and the reason
I'm talking about brie Larson
specifically is because from the looks
of the amount of weight training she was
doing she got the female Marvel bought
equivalent
she's never shows it off in the movie
necessarily nor does she have to
character building I would imagine it
affects the way you hold yourself yeah
yeah absolutely it's just funny that she
got the bomb but doesn't have to show it
off in a reskin way yeah our first
reaction is oh she did yeah for the most
part most of them before and after - we
talked about the bods mainly because
that's what this video voters thought
yeah you're right there you got your
life together you got a better body or a
couple of you were comedians and now
you're not only comedians yeah I would
say Chris Hemsworth though is the one
who has had the opportunity through the
MCU to display a lot of his range
because a lot of these actors had a
chance to step into the superhero medium
like oh well I've been doing this work
I'm known for this now but now there's
my chance to prove myself within one of
these movies whereas Chris Hemsworth
wasn't really known until the first Thor
movie then he's used that opportunity to
show a wide variety of capability with
his acting chops starting off with a
more dramatic term but then having to do
like comedy and stuff I think it's
pretty great well you know what's funny
about him is that from what I've heard
Drew Goddard originally recommended him
based off of cabin in the woods and his
performance in that which is a
performance that it's got a lot of
shades of irony obviously because of
what the movie is and so I thought that
was kind of an animal connection piece
all right guys well those are the eight
actors Screen Rant has listed who else
ever you want transformation who what
who they miss subscribe to Screen Rant
subscribe to the reel rejects click the
notification Bell last but not least
Lance door and Cal durian see penny
curse I thought it'd be fun for this
month for our patrons to do some
fanfiction of them
what if they met each other so I wrote
this one today for a Cal durian our
handsome Native American man from
Colorado and Lance door
our handsome Canadian firefighter
exterior house nighttime a home has been
burnt to ashes
Kaldur and seep in aku's sits at an
ambulance when a firefighter Lance door
approaches him sorry about your homey I
moved to Canada for its free health care
my home burns down I guess I really am
like Jean Grey what do you mean Jean
Grey is my favorite color book character
I guess the dark phoenix within me left
the stove on and let the matches and i
did it intentionally because i wanted to
collect the insurance money well I'm
just glad you're safe
remember us firefighters are the real
heroes you do look good in that outfit
are you single I'm engaged actually
to a woman I'm straight engaged in
straight that's too bad I mean
congratulations what's her name I want
to say no time why do you question how
to pronounce it cuz her name means
questions Canada laughs what's your name
Cal Doreen see penny coos what does Cal
durian mean my mom made it up she was
probably doped up Oh dope dope lot name
and kids is tight ha I get it cuz
they're Canadian like that guy from the
straight and Rance pitch meetings
inserting Ryan George references is
super easy
barely an inconvenience oh really where
are you from originally dude man dude
try reservation in Colorado I don't know
those words I'm Native American yourself
I wanna say some kind of Asian you don't
know Gregg couldn't remember when he
wrote this he really should stop writing
himself into a corner I should know I'm
also a writer how about you got any
passions outside of firefighting other
than banging my bangin fiance in front
of her New Zealand family eh I'm really
into the movie trivia Schmo town Polk
rec and Shawn are horrible at that game
if they keep inviting them back makes no
sense
but do you remember when John degraded
the free-for-all that one year yeah and
he's never had to do anyway
near that great again since he can keep
writing that one special day for the
rest of his life
Gregg definitely wrote this one Gregg
definitely did you know what in your
situation I take the insurance money and
go traveling I once took a trip all
throughout Europe with my extremely hot
fiance
I get it you're straight but you know I
have had fantasies about being with a
Native American man before well maybe I
can help fulfill those fantasies Gregg
always ends these in a weird abrupt
manner Calderone and Lance do it
extremely hard core while the other
firefighters cheer them on the end so we
doing that sir II do it no shots right
too long